you all remember what they say in Show
Business right The Show Must Go On it's
a good thing these fan favorite actors
remembered this Mantra because they were
way too close to quitting before stardom
number one Millie Bobby Brown had a
pretty embarrassing time during
auditions but she is definitely not the
only one with cringy experiences anyways
back to Millie at an early age she was
unfortunately not able to snag anything
that would Propel her career I think I
was just very disheartened by the
rejection after all the rejection Millie
was given an audition for Game of
Thrones got a nose for that however this
audition for her was so embarrassing
that she really just wanted to quit out
of the industry early but as if Destiny
had other plans for her she was given an
audition for the show that made her
famous stranger things the rest is
history of course number two we love
Robert Pattinson but this made us cringe
a little for him Robert had already made
an okay living as a model but when he
was asked to audition for Twilight his
agent told him to bring a guitar for the
scene the kicker here is that he did not
know how to play it so Pattinson
awkwardly lugged this guitar in front of
the casting director and did the scene
we'll let Robert explain what came next
I just walked in and they were like oh
you brought a guitar do you want to play
us a song and I was like no this is the
worst decision I ever made my confidence
just the bed number three from soap
operas to the God of Thunder what a ride
that was early on Chris hemswor course
starred in a whole lot of Australian
soaps before landing the role of
Lieutenant Commander George Kirk in the
Star Trek film you'd think he would
never have trouble finding roles after
that but despite the success of the film
he went into a dry period in acting for
eight months before finally getting the
role of Thor this lengthy point in time
costs Chris to rethink a lot of his
career I was about to quit I always
wanted to act and one of the first
things I wanted to do when I got any
money was pay my parents house off then
my mentality changed which came from
being at a point where I was like I'm
going back to Australia number four
Harry Potter made adult careers super
hard for these three kids with so much
Fame early on Emma Watson became so
overwhelmed by the time Goblet of Fire
premiered that she was ready to leave
acting and the fame it held I think I
was scared I don't know if you ever felt
like it got to a Tipping Point where you
were like this is kind of forever now as
we now know it wasn't forever for Watson
she's gone on to do some amazing
projects chicks after her tenure at
Hogwarts number five it takes two to
tango and to never give up Kristen
Stewart got her first agent when she was
a child but only after a year of
auditioning in just one commercial
booking she just couldn't handle the
rejection anymore she felt horrible
having her mother drive her around Los
Angeles for auditions saying I won't
make my mom drive around Los Angeles
anymore I also got so nervous for every
single audition I was just dying she was
ready to throw in the towel that is
until her mother encouraged her to
toughen up for one last audition for the
safety of objects if I hadn't gotten
that I would have been done number six
Anya Taylor Joy's Pawn was made into a
queen only by the help of her Rook
before she landed the role in Queen's
Gambit she was working on multiple
projects simultaneously and dealing with
the top relationship all of that
emotional stress almost cost her to quit
the business indefinitely I had been
working back to back just before Emma
I've done two projects at the same time
and I was going through some emotional
relationship stuff and that's when her
close friend Mia gave her the push she
needed and got her back on track no that
would be really bad you can't not have
to think that is your oxygen number
seven a true hero will fall at some
point in their Journey long before Gal
Gadot achieved stardom for the role of
Wonder Woman she was working a lot as an
actress and model in Tel Aviv she would
audition for so many projects in
Hollywood but she never broke through
this profession the rejection dude it's
a toughness it wasn't until she
auditioned for Wonder Woman and pushed
so hard to get the role that she finally
made her Mark she inspirationally said
it's also proof that everything happens
for a reason I was on the verge of
giving up acting and then this happened
number eight you can still quit while
you're on top and all it takes is one
project Jennifer Aniston had
contemplated quitting the business after
a rough experience during during filming
an unnamed project this experience was
so rough for her that she thought about
quitting I would have to say the last
two years that quitting has crossed my
mind which it never did before the
project had sucked the life out of me I
don't know if this is what interests me
number nine the worst of tragedies can
sometimes cause us to fall back into
normal life Mark Ruffalo had achieved
success in the early 2000s but after the
passing of his brother he decided to
pack up his family and leave Hollywood
he just never thought he would get back
into it being that his brother was
highly regarded in that Community number
10 being a child in Showbiz is tougher
than you think for Brie Larson she
auditioned so much as a child and teen
but never got a role she took rejection
so personally and even ran away from
home a few times I ran around the block
and then came back after taking multiple
breaks and focusing on other Ventures
she was able to find true love with the
craft itself rather than just focusing
on getting the role this is what feels
like my purpose it feels like what I'm
here to do number 11 Daniel caluya just
really wanted to get out before getting
his star role after his breakout role on
black mirror in the episode 15 million
merits he was surprisingly not booking
any jobs when it came time to audition
for get out Daniel was not in a good
space with acting I was really
disillusioned with acting I had stopped
acting for like a year and a half I
checked out because I was just like this
isn't working when he booked that
life-changing role it changed his
mindset completely Jordan Peele quite
literally saved his career number 12
Henry Cavill auditioned for Twilight
we're not saying that he wouldn't have
been perfect or anything but his
audition for Edward was actually far
from perfect it was so horrible in fact
that he was about ready to throw in the
cape the audition was one of the worst
auditions I did in my whole life I
remember calling my parents and saying
I'm done I can't torture myself anymore
number 13 inspiration can come from
anyone not just the old wise folks
Michael B Jordan did a lot to get his
role in Fruitvale Station he went to
hundreds of auditions and got constant
rejections causing him to think about
quitting more than a few times by the
time filming had begun Michael was tired
of the business but all it took was an
inspiration like director Ryan coogler
to keep him grounded he's the reason why
I have the self-confidence to go out
there and do it behind the camera to see
somebody my age taking care of however
many hundreds of millions of dollars
this movie is it's inspiring it lets me
know that I can do that as well number
14 you do too much in a short amount of
time and it'll burn you out real quick
this was the case for Channing Tatum who
had done a whopping 20 films in a span
of six years he thought he'd done enough
and maybe it was time to retire from the
industry he said I took four movies back
back to back without any time off and I
wasn't as good as I wanted to be in
those last two movies because I didn't
have the energy I asked myself do I want
to act anymore number 15 can you imagine
how annoying it must be to be a child
star having so many people ordering you
around and breathing down your neck Cole
Sprouse had enough of all of that
nonsense he decided it was best to
pursue what he wanted to pursue it
wasn't until he experienced a life that
he returned to Hollywood for the hit
show in Riverdale I didn't know how it
was going to be but uh it was so much
fun who could ever imagine stranger
things without Millie and we can't even
fathom a Thor without Chris but do you
disagree with us was there someone else
who would have made one of their roles
iconic let us know in the comments
thank you